It's only getting every customer's order right. It's only a point-of-sale system connected by Spectrum fiber-powered business internet helping you track hundreds of secure transactions. And it's all backed by 24-7 U.S.-based customer support and local technicians. It's only everything. Get business internet advantage free, forever,
这仅仅是确保每一位顾客的订单准确无误。这仅仅是一个由 Spectrum 光纤商业互联网连接的销售终端系统，帮助您追踪数百笔安全交易。这一切都有全天候的美国本土客户支持和当地技术人员作为后盾。这仅仅是一切。免费获得商业互联网优势，永久免费，
when you get four mobile lines from Spectrum. Visit Spectrum.com slash free for life to find out how. Restrictions apply. Service is not available in all areas. The coronavirus has upended countless lives here at home and around the world. We've all become too familiar with new terms, shelter in place, flatten the curve, social distancing. The stock market is bouncing wildly. Just this week we saw the greatest number of unemployment applications in U.S. history,
当您从 Spectrum 购买四条移动线路时。访问 Spectrum.com/freeforlife 了解详情。受限制条款约束。并非所有地区都提供此服务。新冠病毒已经颠覆了我们国内和世界各地无数人的生活。我们都对“居家令”、“拉平曲线”、“社交距离”等新术语变得过于熟悉。股市剧烈震荡。就在本周，我们目睹了美国历史上最高数量的失业申请，
and there's still no toilet paper at the grocery store if you can even go to the grocery store. So are you feeling stressed yet, anxious at your wits end because you're trying to telework, and the kids are making noise in the next room? And would someone please walk the dog? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the bi-weekly podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychology and everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills.
而且如果你能去杂货店的话，杂货店里还是没有卫生纸。那么，你感到压力了吗？因为试图远程办公而感到焦虑、不知所措，隔壁房间里孩子们还在吵闹？有人能去遛遛狗吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的双周播客，旨在探索心理学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人 Kim Mills。
Joining me today is Dr. Lynn Buffka, senior director of practice research and policy here at APA, the American Psychological Association. Dr. Buffka is also a practicing psychologist and has been talking constantly to, journalists who are covering the coronavirus pandemic. Normally, Lynn and I would be in the APA recording studio together, but because of the virus, we are teleworking and sheltering in place. So, Lynn, welcome to speaking of psychology. Thank you for inviting me. So for the last couple of weeks,
今天加入我的是美国心理学会（APA）实践研究与政策高级主任 Lynn Buffka 博士。Buffka 博士也是一位执业心理学家，一直在与报道新冠疫情的记者们进行持续交流。通常，Lynn 和我会一起在 APA 的录音室里，但由于病毒的原因，我们正在远程办公并居家隔离。所以，Lynn，欢迎来到《心理学谈话》。谢谢你的邀请。那么在过去几周里，
you've been talking almost nonstop to reporters who are trying to present information that will help their readers and listeners cope in these strange times. What are they asking you and what kinds of tips have you been giving them? Well, they're asking me all the time. Are people stressed? And of course, people are going to feel some degree of stress right now. This is a new situation. It's unprecedented. And trying to figure out how do we cope with something that nobody who's alive today can remember ever having happened in our country before. We don't have a roadmap.
你几乎不停地与记者交谈，他们试图提供信息来帮助读者和听众应对这些奇怪的时期。他们问你什么，你给了他们什么样的建议？嗯，他们一直在问我。人们感到压力吗？当然，人们现在会感到某种程度的压力。这是一个新的情况。这是前所未有的。试图弄清楚我们如何应对当今活着的人都不记得在我国发生过的事情。我们没有路线图。
We don't know where to go with this. So, of course, anytime we're faced with that level of ambiguity and uncertainty, it can be stressful for individuals. So we start talking about stress and how is it impacting people. and are there people who are particularly vulnerable to stress at this time? Here, speaking of psychology, we did a podcast on February 10th about the virus when it was far more contained globally and had hardly even touched the United States. As we speak, which is on March 27th, the United States has reached a grim milestone. The U.S. has now surpassed Italy and China as the country with the highest number of confirmed COVID-19 cases. more than 1,100 people have died and that number is rising rapidly.
我们不知道该怎么办。所以，当然，当我们面临这种程度的模糊和不确定性时，对个人来说可能会有压力。所以我们开始谈论压力以及它如何影响人们。此时此刻是否有特别容易受到压力影响的人？在这里，《心理学谈话》中，我们在 2月10日做了一期关于病毒的播客，当时它在全球范围内得到了更好的控制，几乎还没有触及美国。在我们说话的时候，也就是 3月27日，美国已经达到了一个严峻的里程碑。美国现在已经超过意大利和中国，成为新冠肺炎确诊病例最多的国家。超过 1100 人死亡，而且这个数字正在迅速上升。
So what does this information do to people's stress levels and what do they do? What can they do to cope? Well, that certainly makes the COVID-19 crisis seem far more real when we know that we have that many cases in this country. You know, six weeks ago when I was talking with reporters about it, the message was still the same. We need to try to identify what we're afraid of, try to address those fears, figure out how to cope. and do what we need to do in order to protect ourselves and support our communities. But at the time, the threat was fairly distant, and it was a question of would it actually come to us? So people felt a little more relaxed being out, doing the things that they were regularly doing.
那么这些信息对人们的压力水平有什么影响，他们该怎么办？他们能做些什么来应对？嗯，当我们知道这个国家有这么多病例时，这当然会让新冠危机看起来真实得多。你知道，六周前我和记者谈论这件事时，信息还是一样的。我们需要试着找出我们害怕什么，试着解决这些恐惧，弄清楚如何应对。并做我们需要做的事情来保护自己并支持我们的社区。但当时，威胁还相当遥远，这是一个它是否真的会来到我们身边的问题？所以人们在外面做他们经常做的事情时感觉稍微放松了一些。
That's changed dramatically. We are all trying to figure out a new situation, a new way of operating, a new way of surviving for many people. People who don't have jobs right now are not able to work because of the kind of work. that they did is very much in the public. So it's a very stressful time for people who have no way to support themselves, to figure out how they're going to put food on their table for their families. So that's a particular group that's really having a difficult time right now. And then you've got a whole bunch of people across the country who are trying to figure out what exactly does shelter in place mean. What's essential? Is it essential for me to go out to the store and get some bananas because
情况发生了巨大的变化。我们都在试图弄清楚一种新的情况，一种新的运作方式，对许多人来说是一种新的生存方式。现在没有工作的人因为他们所做的工作类型非常公开而无法工作。所以对于那些无法养活自己、无法弄清楚如何为家人提供食物的人来说，这是一个压力很大的时期。所以这是一个目前确实处境艰难的特定群体。然后全国有一大群人试图弄清楚“居家令”到底意味着什么。什么是必要的？我出去到商店买些香蕉是必要的吗，因为
we're out or do I just wait once a week and try and get everything possible and we eat whatever it is that we've got left by the end of the week? How do I do this? What's the rhythm? And of course, as you said at the beginning, how do I live my life when I've got all these other people or maybe no one else in my house? But it's either me alone all the time or me with the same three, four, five people and nobody else. Very different way of how we're going about our days. So what's the answer? I mean, how do people stay connected? And is it okay to take a walk or go to the grocery store? You know, and the recommendations vary on that. Certainly, we are asked to stay at home to not be out and about in public to any great degree because the transmissibility of the virus is quite concerning. And the severity of the
我们用完了，还是我一周等一次，尽量把所有可能的东西都买齐，然后到周末我们吃剩下的任何东西？我该怎么做？节奏是什么？当然，正如你在一开始所说，当我家里有所有这些其他人，或者也许没有其他人时，我该如何生活？要么是我一直一个人，要么是我和同样的三、四、五个人在一起，没有别人。我们度过日子的方式非常不同。那么答案是什么？我的意思是，人们如何保持联系？散步或去杂货店可以吗？你知道，关于这一点的建议各不相同。当然，我们被要求待在家里，不要在很大程度上在公共场合走动，因为病毒的传播性非常令人担忧。而且人们所患的
illness that people have is quite concerning. So the more we can do to reduce transmission, the better likelihood we have of our health care system catching up and being able to respond to the need. So trying to limit our trips out and do the things that we need in order to have food for our table and whatever it is that we need in our homes. That's really critical right now. It depends where you live, though. In a more urban area, you have many more potential contacts with individuals who may be carrying the virus that you may be in contact with. So your risk is going to be higher in those kinds of settings. If you live in a more suburban or rural area, you may be able to be out and still maintain that recommended physical distance of six feet or more between yourself and others.
疾病的严重程度非常令人担忧。所以我们能做的减少传播的事情越多，我们的医疗系统赶上并能够响应需求的可能性就越大。所以尽量限制我们外出，做我们需要做的事情，以便为我们的餐桌提供食物，以及我们在家里需要的任何东西。这在目前确实至关重要。不过，这取决于你住在哪里。在更城市化的地区，你与可能携带病毒的个人有更多的潜在接触，你可能会与他们接触。所以你在这些环境中的风险会更高。如果你住在更郊区或农村地区，你也许能够外出，同时仍然保持建议的六英尺或更远的身体距离。
So there's no perfect answer to how to do that. The recommendation is to really look at what the leading healthcare sources are saying, the CDC, what your local community is telling you to do in terms of how to protect yourself from the virus. Because at the same time, you're also trying to maintain your emotional and physical well-being. And for many people, part of that is regular physical activity. We know that connecting with nature really helps people to feel more balanced and sustained. So there's always pros and cons of trying to reduce your risk for any possible connection with the virus while still also doing things that keep you healthy. And for many people, that is a walk, that is being outside. So it requires really thinking through what your risks are based on the environment and the setting that you're in as well.
所以关于如何做到这一点没有完美的答案。建议是真正看看领先的医疗来源在说什么，CDC，你的当地社区在如何保护自己免受病毒侵害方面告诉你做什么。因为与此同时，你也在努力维持你的情感和身体健康。对于许多人来说，其中一部分是定期的体育活动。我们知道与大自然的联系确实有助于人们感到更平衡和持续。所以试图减少你与病毒发生任何可能联系的风险，同时仍然做让你保持健康的事情，总是有利有弊。对于许多人来说，那是一次散步，那是待在外面。所以这确实需要根据你所处的环境和背景来仔细考虑你的风险。
So some people are pretty stressed. They're very anxious. They're freaking out over the whole situation. And one resource that's available to a lot of people is telepsychology. Could you explain what that is and how it works and if there are any limitations? So, for example, can people take advantage of it no matter where they live? Right. The question about providing health care via technology, we've expanded that capacity across the
所以有些人压力很大。他们非常焦虑。他们对整个情况感到恐慌。许多人可以利用的一种资源是远程心理学。你能解释一下那是什么以及它是如何工作的，以及是否有任何限制吗？例如，无论人们住在哪里，他们都能利用它吗？是的。关于通过技术提供医疗保健的问题，我们在过去几周内扩大了整个
healthcare system in the past couple of weeks. All sorts of medical visits are happening virtually now, whether it's dermatology, whether it's a primary cure visit, and yes, even with mental health. You can receive psychological services via technology. Some providers, some psychologists have been doing that for quite a while. Lots of psychologists are figuring out how to do that now. So there's questions about what kinds of technology really to sustain that continuity of care, video conferencing where you can actually see the other person makes a big difference.
医疗系统的能力。现在各种各样的医疗访问都在虚拟地进行，无论是皮肤科，还是初级保健访问，是的，即使是心理健康也是如此。你可以通过技术获得心理服务。一些提供者，一些心理学家已经这样做了一段时间了。许多心理学家现在正在弄清楚如何做到这一点。所以关于什么样的技术真正能够维持这种护理的连续性存在疑问，你可以真正看到对方的视频会议有很大的不同。
People really like that connection or via the phone is another way that's happening. And yes, that can be available in lots of places for people to access care that way. There's a couple of challenges. One is making sure that psychologists and other mental and behavioral health providers have the technology to provide. services via video conferencing and feel comfortable and competent to do so. So they're all working rapidly to develop that capacity so that they can meet the need. And then there's also the question of finding somebody who has the availability and is appropriately licensed. Ideally, we see health care providers who are licensed in the jurisdiction that we live in, that we reside in.
人们真的很喜欢那种联系，或者通过电话是正在发生的另一种方式。是的，这可以在很多地方供人们以这种方式获得护理。有几个挑战。一个是确保心理学家和其他心理和行为健康提供者拥有通过视频会议提供服务并感到舒适和胜任的技术。所以他们都在迅速努力发展这种能力，以便他们能够满足需求。然后还有寻找一个有空闲时间且获得适当许可的人的问题。理想情况下，我们看在我们的管辖区，我们居住的地方获得许可的医疗保健提供者。
That's how traditionally health care has worked. And that's done in order to protect the public so that you as the, the receiver of services have, know that there's an oversight body ensuring that the health care professional, the psychologist or whoever, has appropriate credentials, training, maintains their license, does what is expected by the state, by the jurisdiction to maintain their competence. Right now, there is some relaxation of those requirements for people to be licensed in the jurisdiction in which they're seeing somebody. So in some places you can quote unquote see a psychologist across state line.
这就是传统上医疗保健运作的方式。这样做是为了保护公众，以便作为服务接收者的你，知道有一个监督机构确保医疗保健专业人员，心理学家或其他人，拥有适当的凭据、培训，维持他们的执照，做州、管辖区期望的事情以维持他们的能力。目前，对于人们在他们看人的管辖区获得许可的要求有一些放宽。所以在某些地方，你可以“引用”跨州看心理学家。
So I live in Maryland. I might be seeing a patient who lives in the District of Columbia. And some places allow that. States are working rapidly to determine what they need to do in order for their regulations to accommodate this need right now of trying to ensure care gets to the people who need it. Because just because we have a virus doesn't mean we stop having people. with mental health concerns such as depression or schizophrenia or post-traumatic stress disorder who really need care for those issues as well as individuals who are feeling an increased amount of stress and distress because of the world that we're currently living in and the uncertainty
所以我住在马里兰州。我可能正在看一位住在哥伦比亚特区的病人。有些地方允许这样做。各州正在迅速努力确定他们需要做什么，以便他们的法规能够适应目前试图确保护理到达需要它的人手中的需求。因为仅仅因为我们有病毒并不意味着我们停止拥有患有抑郁症、精神分裂症或创伤后应激障碍等心理健康问题的人，他们确实需要对这些问题进行护理，以及因为我们目前生活的世界和与病毒相关的不确定性而感到压力和痛苦增加的个人。
related to the virus. What about insurance? How do I know if my insurance is going to cover this kind of patient care? That's a great question. And the first thing, if you are able to do so, call your insurer or go. to the insurer's website and see what it says there. Medicare is making changes to allow greater telehealth, greater access to telehealth. And private payers, other kinds of insurers, typically follow Medicare's lead. At the APA, we're working really hard to try to identify what
保险呢？我怎么知道我的保险是否会覆盖这种病人护理？这是一个很好的问题。如果可以的话，第一件事，打电话给你的保险公司或去保险公司的网站看看上面说了什么。医疗保险（Medicare）正在做出改变，以允许更多的远程医疗，更多的远程医疗访问。私人付款人，其他类型的保险公司，通常遵循医疗保险的领导。在 APA，我们正在非常努力地试图确定
the states are saying is permissible and not permissible and putting together content so our members can advocate with the insurers in their locality to try to, to be certain that the care will be covered, whether it's provided via technology or not. But if in doubt, call your insurance company and ask that question and tell them that there's important reasons for this to happen. The data suggests care can be just as effective delivered via technology. It may feel different at first because we're used to being face-to-face when we receive our health care.
各州说什么是允许的，什么是不允许的，并整理内容，以便我们的成员可以在他们当地与保险公司进行宣传，试图确定护理是否会被覆盖，无论它是否通过技术提供。但如果有疑问，打电话给你的保险公司并问这个问题，并告诉他们这发生有重要的原因。数据表明，通过技术提供的护理可以同样有效。起初可能会感觉不同，因为我们习惯于在接受医疗保健时面对面。
But the data suggests for mental health concerns that it can be just as effective if it's delivered via both video conferencing and the telephone. That's great to know. So just to be clear, now, Medicare is insurance that covers seniors, people who are generally over 65 and aren't working and have other insurance. But what about Medicaid? What about people who are lower income who may be relying on Medicaid? Right. Medicaid is a insurance that is determined state by state by state. Medicaid too is also, on a state-by-state basis, making more flexibility in terms of the options for how care is delivered. Because many people who receive Medicaid are also at risk, at higher risk for coronavirus than the average people in the population, because these are individuals who have perhaps other kinds of health conditions or perhaps not able to work because of health conditions, right? So they need to have Medicaid as their insurance, but it also means because of the health conditions, they might be more vulnerable to COVID-19, thereby making it even more of a priority that those individuals have access to care through technology.
但数据表明，对于心理健康问题，如果通过视频会议和电话提供，它可以同样有效。很高兴知道这一点。所以为了清楚起见，现在，医疗保险是覆盖老年人的保险，通常超过 65 岁且不工作并有其他保险的人。但医疗补助（Medicaid）呢？那些可能依赖医疗补助的低收入人群呢？是的，医疗补助是一种由州逐州确定的保险。医疗补助也在州的基础上，在护理如何提供方面做出更多的灵活性。因为许多接受医疗补助的人也处于风险中，比人口中的普通人更容易受到冠状病毒的风险，因为这些人可能患有其他类型的健康状况，或者可能因为健康状况而无法工作，对吧？所以他们需要医疗补助作为他们的保险，但这也就意味着因为健康状况，他们可能更容易受到新冠病毒的影响，从而使这些人通过技术获得护理成为更优先的事项。
But it's not a given that it's going to happen in every single state. As an organization, APA is working on these kinds of issues as are other health care organizations. I am hopeful that we will see a lot more flexibility in terms of how care gets paid for, what kind of care gets paid for. So long as we're providing quality care and meeting the needs of our patients and can demonstrate that, I hope that payers will still see the benefits then for paying for that care, regardless of whether it's delivered in person or delivered over the phone. What's happening for people who have, say, substance use issues?
但这并不是说它会在每一个州发生。作为一个组织，APA 正在处理这些类型的问题，其他医疗保健组织也是如此。我希望我们将看到在护理如何支付、什么样的护理被支付方面有更多的灵活性。只要我们提供高质量的护理并满足我们病人的需求并能证明这一点，我希望付款人仍然会看到支付该护理的好处，无论它是亲自提供还是通过电话提供。对于那些有，比如说，物质使用问题的人来说，发生了什么？
Maybe they're in recovery. They've been going to AA or NA meetings. and now they can't. What are they supposed to be doing? Well, I've just learned recently there are some great online resources for A&NA, and for anybody in that situation strongly encourage you to look for those. A friend of mine just sent me a link to a whole bunch of resources for online N.A. And I've heard wonderful things for people who've connected with groups.
也许他们正在康复中。他们一直在参加 AA 或 NA 会议，现在他们不能了。他们应该做什么？嗯，我最近刚了解到有一些很棒的 AA 和 NA 在线资源，对于处于这种情况的任何人，强烈建议你寻找这些。我的一个朋友刚给我发了一个关于在线 NA 的大量资源的链接。我听说过人们与团体联系的精彩事情。
So it is possible to get that kind of support through online. through virtual means, but it's going to be different, right? We're going to have to make a little extra effort to find the right one that works for us and to make those connections. Part of why AA and NA is so valuable is that individuals are in a group with others who've had similar experiences, and that can be a very powerful support for someone trying to make significant changes in their life. Getting that support through virtual means is possible and can make a difference.
所以通过在线，通过虚拟方式获得那种支持是可能的，但这会是不同的，对吧？我们将不得不付出一点额外的努力来找到适合我们的那个，并建立那些联系。AA 和 NA 如此有价值的部分原因是个人与有类似经历的其他人在一起，这对试图在生活中做出重大改变的人来说可能是一个非常强大的支持。通过虚拟方式获得那种支持是可能的，并且可以对
a person's life. And I would say it's critical in order for someone to maintain the kind of lifestyle, the sobriety that they have been attaining in their life and to keep sustain that because that's going to be critical for long-term well-being. When we're under stress, there's the challenge of feeling pulled into the things that make us feel good in the short term. And substances can make us feel good in the short term. But the long run can be really problematic for people who've got a history of not using them and using them well and in abusing them and having problems with that. So anything we can do to help ourselves, help the people we care about, not return to that path will be critical right now.
一个人的生活产生影响。我想说，为了让某人维持他们在生活中一直获得的某种生活方式、清醒，并保持这种状态，这是至关重要的，因为这对长期健康至关重要。当我们处于压力之下时，会有被拉向那些让我们在短期内感觉良好的事情的挑战。物质可以在短期内让我们感觉良好。但长期来看，对于那些有不使用它们、使用它们很好、滥用它们并因此遇到问题历史的人来说，这可能真的很有问题。所以任何我们能做的事情来帮助自己，帮助我们关心的人，不回到那条道路上，在目前都是至关重要的。
And of course, there are a lot of applications out there that allow you to reach out to your friends. And if you've got sponsors, if you're in a program where you need to do that, I mean, you can do that online, right? There's Zoom and Skype and many ways of connecting now, FaceTime. Absolutely. I mean, it feels like, it feels a little hard right now because it's different, right? It was easy to show up at a meeting and see your sponsor.
当然，有很多应用程序允许你联系你的朋友。如果你有赞助人，如果你在一个需要这样做的项目中，我的意思是，你可以在线做，对吧？现在有 Zoom 和 Skype 以及许多联系方式，FaceTime。绝对。我的意思是，它感觉，它现在感觉有点难，因为它不同，对吧？去参加会议并见到你的赞助人很容易。
Now you have to make a little more effort to connect to your sponsor in a different way. But once you create that pattern, create that habit of doing it, and this would be for any connections that people have in their lives. Once you make these new connections, have a standing date with your best friend on Tuesday nights, it will become easier to do those connections in new ways. and you can still get that same sort of intimate close connection that can be sustaining and provide the support that we all really want right now. So some of us out here are in quarantine, maybe because we've been exposed to someone with the virus or maybe even have the virus but aren't sick enough to be in the hospital. These are people who are probably experienced a host of even different feelings. What are the psychological impacts of quarantine and what can people do to manage that? Yeah, we know that quarantine can be hard.
现在你必须付出一点更多的努力以不同的方式联系你的赞助人。但一旦你创造了那种模式，创造了那样做的习惯，这对人们生活中的任何联系都是如此。一旦你建立了这些新的联系，周二晚上和你最好的朋友有一个固定的约会，以新的方式进行这些联系就会变得更容易。你仍然可以得到那种我们现在都真正想要的、可以维持并提供支持的亲密联系。所以我们这里的一些人正在隔离，也许是因为我们接触了病毒携带者，或者甚至可能携带病毒但没有病到需要住院。这些人可能经历了更多不同感受的集合。隔离的心理影响是什么，人们可以做些什么来管理它？是的，我们知道隔离可能很难。
If we're not sick, but we're in quarantine, we're doing this for the larger good, really. We're doing it to try to prevent population, widespread population disease. And remembering that and remember that altruistic value of we're doing something for the larger community helps us accept the situation that we're in. But it's not surprising that people are going to feel some boredom, are going to feel irritation, unhappy, feel like it's unfair. acknowledge those feelings. Recognize that that's what you're feeling, accept that that's how you're feeling, but then move from that. Try to let go of it and focus on the things that you do have. If you're not sick, you still have your health. You hopefully have access to the resources that you need or you can begin to problem solve for how to get access to those resources and you can do
如果我们没有生病，但我们在隔离，我们这样做是为了更大的利益，真的。我们这样做是为了试图防止人口，广泛的人口疾病。记住这一点，记住我们正在为更大的社区做某事的利他价值，有助于我们接受我们所处的处境。但人们会感到一些无聊、会感到烦躁、不快乐、觉得不公平，这并不奇怪。承认这些感受。认识到这就是你的感受，接受这就是你的感受，但然后从那里走出来。试着放下它，专注于你拥有的东西。如果你没有生病，你仍然拥有你的健康。你希望能够获得你需要的资源，或者你可以开始解决如何获得这些资源的问题，你可以做
things to try to find ways to connect online, even if you're not interacting physically with others. If you are sick with COVID-19, you're staying quarantined in order to not spread it in the community. That's critical. Hopefully, you have somebody who can provide you with the assistance you need while you're sick because you could be really sick and not have the energy to get out there and do what you would normally do or even to get yourself fed. So trying to do the things. And to keep your health going while you're in quarantine will be your critical step when you have the sickest part of it. For anyone who has not yet had the disease, but the potential is there, now would be a good time to think about how would I manage quarantine if that happens to me.
事情来试图找到在线联系的方式，即使你没有与他人进行身体互动。如果你患有新冠肺炎，你保持隔离是为了不在社区中传播它。这至关重要。希望你有人可以在你生病时为你提供你需要的帮助，因为你可能病得很重，没有精力出去做你通常会做的事情，甚至无法让自己吃饱。所以试着做这些事情。在你隔离期间保持你的健康将是你处于最严重阶段时的关键步骤。对于任何尚未患病，但潜力存在的人来说，现在是考虑如果发生在我身上，我将如何管理隔离的好时机。
And do I have enough in my household? Am I able to get sufficient supplies in my household? Should I become sick and unable to go out? So use the time right now to begin to begin to have, you know, even if it's two weeks worth of canned soup and that's why you eat for two weeks, that's what you eat. At least it's there. It's something you don't have to worry about and be stressed about should the event that people fear happen. And that is to actually develop sickness because of the virus. So do you have any advice for people who are teleworking, but they also have their kids at home
我的家里有足够的储备吗？如果我生病且无法外出，我能够在家中获得足够的供应吗？所以利用现在的时间开始，开始拥有，你知道，即使是两周的罐装汤，那就是你吃两周的东西，那就是你吃的。至少它在那里。这是你不需要担心和感到压力的事情，如果人们担心的事情发生的话。那就是因为病毒而真正发展出疾病。所以你对那些正在远程办公，但他们家里也有孩子的人有什么建议吗？
and maybe they need to be helping them with the schoolwork or they're fighting over who gets to use the computer when? How can people deal with that? For all of us right now with these changed circumstances, giving ourselves a little grace and giving the people we live with a little grace is going to go a long way. We're all feeling some feelings maybe we weren't having a couple weeks ago and they may come out in surprising ways. Recognizing that, being a little more patient with yourself and the others in your household is a good starting point. But then talk with the other adults in your household about what each of you is hoping to accomplish. while you're under this time being at home.
也许他们需要帮助他们完成学业，或者他们在争论谁能使用电脑？人们如何处理这个问题？对于我们所有人来说，在这些改变了的情况下，给自己一点宽容，给和我们住在一起的人一点宽容，会大有帮助。我们都在感受一些我们几周前可能没有的感受，它们可能会以令人惊讶的方式表现出来。认识到这一点，对自己和家里的其他人多一点耐心是一个很好的起点。但然后与你家里的其他成年人谈谈你们每个人都希望完成什么。当你处于这段在家里的时间时。
How can you best do that in ways that feel balanced and fair so that you each are able to work? If that's what you're both trying to do, as well as parent take care of other household responsibilities, try to have a game plan with the people that you live with. And then think about the kids, what are their needs right now? You know, for really young kids, really, they just want to have a stable base. They want to feel loved. They want to know that they've got the attention of the people who are important in their lives. For older kids, you're going to be thinking about trying to maintain some structure with them
你如何以感觉平衡和公平的方式最好地做到这一点，以便你们每个人都能工作？如果这是你们俩都试图做的事情，以及照顾其他家庭责任，试着和你住在一起的人有一个游戏计划。然后想想孩子们，他们现在有什么需求？你知道，对于非常小的孩子，真的，他们只是想有一个稳定的基础。他们想感到被爱。他们想知道他们得到了他们生活中重要的人的关注。对于大一点的孩子，你将考虑试图与他们保持某种结构
and help them continue with their learning, but it's not going to be perfect by any means at all. And certainly middle school kids and teenagers and college students who are suddenly home and weren't expecting this are going to have an array of emotions just like their parents and the other adults in the house. Giving them space to acknowledge those emotions is important. But once you've done all that, try to figure out routines that are going to work for your household. There's no perfect answer, but having some expectations around who gets to have access to the computer when, trying to carve out some workspace, some physical workspace, so that others in the house understand that if you're sitting in this chair with a laptop in front of you, that's when you're working. You will let them know when you can be disturbed because not all of your one is going to have the luxury of having private spaces to work in. So figuring out ways to communicate to others, here's my work time, here's my workspace.
并帮助他们继续学习，但这绝不会是完美的。当然，突然回家且没预料到这一点的中学生、青少年和大学生，会像他们的父母和家里的其他成年人一样有各种各样的情绪。给他们空间承认这些情绪很重要。但一旦你做了所有这些，试着找出适合你家庭的常规。没有完美的答案，但围绕谁能在什么时候使用电脑有一些期望，试着开辟一些工作空间，一些物理工作空间，以便家里其他人明白如果你坐在椅子上，面前放着笔记本电脑，那就是你在工作的时候。你会让他们知道什么时候可以打扰你，因为不是每个人都有奢侈的私人空间来工作。所以找出与他人沟通的方式，这是我的工作时间，这是我的工作空间。
I need you to respect that is going to be critical in order to have some functioning and continue to work down the road. If you're able to work from home and it's tough going, talk to your managers too. They may also be experiencing some tough times with teleworking, see how you can work out some new solutions with them. That might be you could start working super early in the morning for a few hours. Then you're on the parent shift or you're on the take care of the household shift for a while, but you return to your task later in the day.
我需要你尊重这一点，为了有一些功能并继续工作，这将是至关重要的。如果你能在家工作，而且进展艰难，也和你的经理谈谈。他们可能也在远程办公方面经历一些困难时期，看看你们如何与他们制定一些新的解决方案。那可能是你可以每天早上超早工作几个小时。然后你轮到父母班，或者你轮到照顾家庭班一段时间，但你会在一天晚些时候回到你的任务。
Work with your colleagues to figure out strategies so that the essential work can get done while we all adjust to this new, what we hope will be a temporary reality. I think another challenge is knowing when your workday actually ends because we're all plugged in all the time and it's really easy just to keep working even when, hello, it's six o'clock and maybe I should knock off. Oh, absolutely. And I have found for me having a dedicated workspace and keeping pretty much to my regular work hours has been important. But I don't have the distraction of a young child.
与你的同事合作找出策略，以便在我们都适应这个我们希望是暂时现实的新事物时，可以完成基本工作。我认为另一个挑战是知道你的工作日实际上什么时候结束，因为我们一直都在插电，即使在，你好，六点钟了，也许我应该收工了，也很容易继续工作。哦，绝对。我发现对我来说，拥有一个专门的工作空间并基本保持我的正常工作时间很重要。但我没有幼儿的干扰。
And I have a little separation of space. For people who are trying to balance more hands-on parenting and work, that becomes more of a challenge. But if you don't have that extra challenge of kids that are demanding your attention all the time, finding a way to sort of be clear to end your work day, to walk away from that space and create some ritual to change to, okay, now I'm home for the day and I'm offline, I'm not working, is really important. For most of us, that's our commute. Even if our commute was a 10-minute drive home from the office, that was a transition time. It's still good to build in the transition time even when we're working from home. The transition may need to be longer than the 50 feet from your desk to the kitchen where you're
我有一点空间的分离。对于那些试图平衡更多亲力亲为的育儿和工作的人来说，这变得更具挑战性。但如果你没有孩子一直需要你注意的额外挑战，找到一种方式来明确结束你的工作日，离开那个空间并创造某种仪式来改变到，好的，现在我回家了，我下线了，我不工作了，这真的很重要。对于我们大多数人来说，那是我们的通勤。即使我们的通勤是从办公室回家的 10 分钟车程，那也是一个过渡时间。即使我们在家工作，建立过渡时间仍然很好。过渡可能需要比从你的办公桌到厨房的 50 英尺更长，你在那里
now fixing dinner. So one of the questions I've been asked by some reporters is what will be the impact of missing some of life's milestones. Some people haven't been able to attend their parents' funeral, for example. And countless young people are going to be deprived of the ritual of graduation from high school or college. What do we know about the long-term impact of missing these ceremonies? I don't know how much we know about the long-term impact of it. But in the immediate moment, there's going to be some grief. There's certainly going to be some disappointment about this. it may feel very unfair, particularly, you know, siblings like, my brother got to have a graduation. I don't have one.
现在准备晚餐。所以记者问我的一些问题之一是，错过一些人生里程碑的影响会是什么。例如，有些人无法参加父母的葬礼。无数年轻人将被剥夺高中或大学毕业的仪式。我们对错过这些仪式的长期影响了解多少？我不知道我们对它的长期影响了解多少。但在即刻的时刻，会有一些悲伤。关于这一点肯定会有一些失望。它可能会感觉非常不公平，特别是，你知道，兄弟姐妹就像，我哥哥能有毕业典礼。我没有。
Or, you know, she got to go to prom last year and now I'll never have a prom. So there's clearly going to be some disappointment, some grief about this. You clearly are not going to be the only one not having these experiences because people across the country. And you're actually not, this isn't the first time this is happening to anybody either. My next-door neighbor lost his father over the holidays very unexpectedly. He had planned a whole trip with college friends to go to Europe for a few weeks and canceled all of that. Of course, he's grieving his dad, but he's also really disappointed to lose that experience. This happens to people for a variety of circumstances.
或者，你知道，她去年能去参加舞会，现在我永远不会有舞会了。所以显然会有一些失望，关于这一点的一些悲伤。你显然不会是唯一一个没有这些经历的人，因为全国各地的人们。而且你实际上不是，这也不是第一次发生在任何人身上。我的隔壁邻居在假期里非常意外地失去了他的父亲。他曾计划和大学朋友一起去欧洲旅行几周，并取消了所有这些。当然，他在为他的父亲悲伤，但他也真的很失望失去了那种经历。这种情况因为各种情况发生在人们身上。
We're all in it together this time. The plus of it is perhaps you're able to create down the road a more meaningful way to celebrate these milestones. Perhaps the big graduation ceremony with a speaker that you really weren't that interested in and family putting a lot of money into traveling to get to it didn't have that much appeal to you. Maybe a ceremony that is with the people who matter the most to you and the opportunity to get together with your closest friends from high school or college to celebrate is a more meaningful way to do it. So really encourage people to think about that and how best to do it. But we haven't talked at all about funerals. And I think that's a really important one.
这次我们都在一起。它的好处也许是你能够创造在未来以更有意义的方式庆祝这些里程碑。也许那个你真的不太感兴趣的演讲者的盛大毕业典礼，以及家人花很多钱去参加它，对你没有那么大的吸引力。也许一个与对你最重要的人在一起的仪式，以及与你高中或大学最亲密的朋友聚在一起庆祝的机会，是一种更有意义的方式。所以真的鼓励人们考虑这一点以及如何最好地做到这一点。但我们根本没有谈论葬礼。我认为这是一个非常重要的。
Losing a loved one, whether it's because of COVID-19 or all the other kinds of reasons. People are still sick and dying right now, whether it's cancer or heart attacks or car accidents, grieving is really important. We need to have time and space for that. And the rituals really help us cope with that. We're not necessarily going to have the rituals we expected. And we may not be able to have all the people we care about together with us at that time to get the hugs, but we can still share the tears in different kinds of ways. And it's going to require some flexibility and adaptability to figure that out. But it's going to be essential for people to do that so that they can feel the love of the community around them while they're going through something very difficult,
失去一个亲人，无论是由于新冠肺炎还是所有其他原因。人们现在仍然生病和死亡，无论是癌症还是心脏病发作或车祸，悲伤真的很重要。我们需要有时间和空间来处理它。仪式确实帮助我们应对它。我们不一定会拥有我们预期的仪式。我们可能无法让所有我们关心的人在那个时候和我们在一起得到拥抱，但我们仍然可以用不同的方式分享眼泪。这将需要一些灵活性和适应性来弄清楚这一点。但人们这样做将是至关重要的，这样他们才能在经历非常困难的事情时感受到周围社区的爱，
but also so they can honor the person that they've lost and remember that person in the life that was hopefully very well lived. Yeah, I think that's really important. So Dr. Buffka, you're also under a lot of stress because of the coronavirus and the nature of your job. What are you doing to cope? I'm trying to follow my own advice. So I'm sticking to a routine as much as I can. I still get up in the morning and try to exercise every day. I'm trying to be careful about what I'm eating, that I'm eating fruits and vegetables and not just carboloading because it's really easy if it's right there in your kitchen.
但也为了他们可以纪念他们失去的人，并记住那个希望生活得很好的那个人。是的，我认为这真的很重要。所以 Buffka 博士，你因为冠状病毒和你的工作性质也承受着很大的压力。你正在做什么来应对？我正在努力遵循我自己的建议。所以我尽可能地坚持常规。我仍然每天早上起床并尝试锻炼。我正在努力注意我吃的东西，我正在吃水果和蔬菜，而不是仅仅摄入碳水化合物，因为如果它就在你的厨房里，这真的很容易。
When I go to the office to work, I'm eating the food that I bring. with me. So I'm trying to be thoughtful about the kind of food that I'm eating. I'm exploring some new ways of connecting with distant family. I was supposed to visit my parents next month and that's probably not going to be happening. But we've been figuring out how to connect via Zoom. My father and I've learned how to play a favorite card game together over the phone. So we're trying some new things and we're trying to share ideas with others so that we can learn from that and perhaps have some greater appreciation for when we will be together face to face down the road. And maybe these things are so much fun that we'll keep doing them.
当我去办公室工作时，我吃我带的食物。所以我正在努力思考我吃的食物类型。我正在探索一些与远方家人联系的新方式。我本应下个月去探望我的父母，那可能不会发生。但我们一直在弄清楚如何通过 Zoom 联系。我和我父亲学会了如何通过电话一起玩最喜欢的纸牌游戏。所以我们正在尝试一些新事物，我们正在尝试与他人分享想法，以便我们可以从中学习，并也许对我们未来面对面在一起时有更大的欣赏。也许这些事情太有趣了，我们会继续做它们。
Yeah, I now have a standing date with my father every Tuesday and we're really looking forward to it. Great. Well, Lynn Buffka, thank you so much for joining us today. It's always a pleasure to talk to you. I hope you've helped some of our listeners feel better and a little bit more control of their lives. I hope so, too, because it's not an easy time right now, but we need to really think about
是的，我现在每周二和我父亲都有一个固定的约会，我们真的很期待它。太好了。好吧，Lynn Buffka，非常感谢你今天加入我们。和你交谈总是一种乐趣。我希望你已经帮助我们的一些听众感觉更好，对他们的生活有了一点更多的控制。我也希望如此，因为现在不是一个容易的时期，但我们需要真正考虑
that basic foundation. of ensuring we're getting our activity, our physical connections, I mean our social connections with others when we're not able to physically be with them. And to just recognize that we've got an array of emotions that we didn't expect to be dealing with right now and it's okay to have them. But we want to make sure that they don't overrun us so that we can look ahead and figure out how do we cope with the situation that we're in. Definitely good advice. Thank you. So for our listeners, if you have any comments or ideas that you want to share about our podcast, you can send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
那个基本基础。确保我们获得我们的活动，我们的身体联系，我的意思是当我们不能身体在一起时我们与他人的社会联系。并且只是认识到我们有一系列我们没预料到现在要处理的情绪，拥有它们是可以的。但我们想确保它们不会压倒我们，以便我们可以展望未来并弄清楚我们如何应对我们所处的处境。绝对是好的建议。谢谢。所以对于我们的听众，如果你有任何关于我们播客的评论或想法想要分享，你可以发送电子邮件到 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部一个词，在 APA.org。
And please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or pretty much wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download all the episodes at www. Thank you for listening. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或几乎任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。你也可以去我们的网站下载所有剧集，网址是 www。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。